لا نعرف عمرها ولا حتى اسمها فكل ما نعرفه
هو انها كانت مع زميلاتها في مدرسه بمنطقه
تسكنها اغلبيه شيعيه في شمال العراق عندما
فجر انتحاري شاحنه ملغومه كان يقودها قرب
المكان
ولم يتوقف مسلسل العنف في العراق بشكل
فعلي فكثيرا ما تحول التفجيرات الاماكن
المستهدفه الى مقابر مثل هذا المقهى الذي
تجمع فيه العديد من الناس لمشاهده لعبه
كره قدم وغالبا ما يلقى بالمسؤوليه في
الهجمات الدمويه على تنظيم القاعده وما
يسمى بدوله العراق الاسلاميه ولطالما
تباهى الجيش الامريكي بمدى نجاح قواته
بكسر شوكه المنظمات الارهابيه ولكن الان
وبعدما يقرب من عامين على انسحاب
الامريكيين بشكل كامل من العراق تتزايد
قوه تنظيم القاعده بشكل لا يمكن انكاره
فقوات الامن العراقيه ليست قادره بشكل
فعلي على تحقيق الاستقرار في البلاد
لاسيما بدون دعم الولايات المتحده في حين
ينظر الى مسلسل العنف والتجاذبات السياسيه
على الساحه العراقيه على انهما خطان
يسيران جنبا الى جنب وفي وقت سابق من هذا
العام سافرنا الى محافظه الانبار السنيه
والتي تعد بؤره تصاعد للغضب ضد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي نور المالكي حيث التقينا
بالعديد من العراقيين الذين اتهموا
الحكومه باضطهاد السنه واعتقالهم بشكل
عشوائي كاذب
ويبدو ان تنظيم القاعده والمتطرفين
استفادوا من تزايد السقط ضد الحكومه
العراقيه التي يقودها الشيعه وتوسيع
نفوذهم وزياده هجماتهم
وفي وقت تستمر فيه موجه الهجمات
الانتقاميه بين السنه والشيعه وصلت اعداد
القتلى في الاشهر الاخيره الى مستويات لم
تشهدها البلاد منذ سنوات
وساهم تسارع الحرب الاهليه في سوريا
بتاجيج الصراع بالعراق حيث وسع تنظيم
القاعده من حده عملياته خلال الصيف وفي
وقت سابق من هذا الاسبوع انحلوا الملك
باللائمه في الحرب الدائره في سوريا لعوده
ظهور تنظيم القاعده والعنف في بلاده
بينما يرى كثيرون ان البنادق والقوات
الجويه لن يستطيعا تحقيق الاستقرار في
البلد الذي يحتاج الى مزيد من النضج
السياسي